ils ont joué les gustave eiffel pendant
six semaines douze techniciens de la
société rambo liten à devait
mécatronique on rénovait le système
électronique du phare de la tour eiffel
parmi eux michel des landes de
techniciens depuis 35 ans dans cette
entreprise
la difficulté c'est les changements à
chaque fois de fargues descendre monte
escalier escalier sur des échelles d
escalier en colimaçon
c'est vrai que c'était assez épuisant ça
un sort d un petit peu des habitudes de
travail
on y vend l'entreprise donc c'est un
très gros projet est très intéressant
installé depuis 2000 certaines pièces
étaient obsolètes des pannes régulières
une rénovation nécessaire de la mise en
mouvement du phare la première demande
et et ça c'était de faire une mise à
jour électronique et une mise à jour de
la mécanique du du phare pour pouvoir
aussi préparer les évolutions les dix
prochaines années
la motorisation électronique la
spécialité da devait mécatronique depuis
cette société a remporté l'appel
d'offres face à une quinzaine
d'entreprises candidates
elle a fait valoir son expérience suite
à une première intervention passé sur la
tour eiffel
il ya bien quatre phares comme chacun
des quatre points cardinaux
chacun des quatre phares éclairent sur
les 90 degrés et lorsqu'il a fini ses 90
premier degré il passe la main au phare
suivant et ainsi de suite pour donner
l'illusion qu'il y a qu un sofa une
illusion qui permet à la dame de fer de
conserver certains secrets sous sa
longue robe d'acier